I really have to start with the most
important question okay what do you have
on Matthew Vaughn and Dexter Fletcher
that keeps getting you like jobs besides
talent it does seem like you know I have
all their skeletons and they're in my
closet no I mean I know not to you know
I think we all get on very well and we
all have quite the three of us have a
very fiery relationships we all
regularly get very grumpy with each
other because you know creative
processes when it's a collaboration and
never are never perfectly smooth but we
have such strength of relationship the
three of us and we care about each other
so much that it's like family we can
shout and scream and raela each other
about what we think should happen and we
always land in a place that the three of
us are comfortable with and so I would
love to see one of those fights in
person yes no they do Matthew and just
going they do happen but you know I love
Matthew and I love Dexter and I mean in
the true sense of the word so you know
we always will was command and I think
the work we've done together we're all
very proud of so I think we just want to
do more of it Lily in the movie was that
actually you falling down the stairs it
was my yeah so what happened was we by
the way that's like a real stunt it is a
real stunt and what I've done I've not a
total stranger to stunts I know Tom
Cruise but I am basically we arrived we
were we were filming quite a way away
outside of London I'm not sure but
anyway that in this big beautiful
country Harris and my stunt double
arrived and I said to Jack office lady
why is why why is he here he said are we
gonna fall down the stairs and I think I
felt like you know the remove ease where
I'm comfortable for a really talented
stunt guy to make me look brilliant like
in certain certain times in Kingsman you
know this movie just didn't feel like
that kind of movie to me I wanted to be
the guy on screen always is much you
know I feel very
I feel quite I want I don't know
possessiveness over especially I thank
you so but because we didn't have a
coordinator I couldn't do it so we
called in a coordinated we got an
emergency stunt coordinator
to come and look over everything and and
they made it safe and of course I've got
some protection on my back and things
and they taught me through the right way
to do it and we did it you know it
didn't hurt at all it was fine it's
absolutely fine
and it's bright and I think it's great
because it's so obviously me and it sort
of makes you good Wow I'm shocking I
vividly I was like oh wow that's really
him yeah we spoke at CinemaCon a while
ago when you were getting ready to film
it I remember yeah it was there I was
there for the for the Robin Hood exactly
and I'm just curious for people that for
people that are curious what goes into
making a movie like this and is my last
question can you just talk a little bit
about the the pre-production process and
really the level of what you have to do
as an actor to get ready for a role like
this I think it's you know you put your
life on hold and you become obsessive
about it and it's sort of all you think
about you know aside from the countless
countless countless hours of fittings
and the makeup tests and me voraciously
kind of trying to absorb as much Elton
John as I can
there's just so much time spent in
studio because I sing in the film we
were just at Abbey Road four months in
advance between February and July but
not every day but you know several times
a week we'd spend hours at Abbey Road
working on tracks discussing ideas all
you know orchestrated by a fantastic
music director Charles Martin and meet
frankly getting my voice ready for the
challenge because there's a lot I do
over 20 songs in the film and and but
that process was a joy I have never
looked forward to going to work so much
partly because of how wonderful Charles
Martin is but also just because I love
to sing and these are some of the
greatest pop rock songs ever written
and um and it's been my great privilege
I've loved it yeah you're fantastic in
there thank you brother thank you so
much thank you